let's talk about the return of religion
i mean uh you know brett just brought up
that things are starting to become more
religious i remember reading about dave
rubin
he is he is he now christian or did he
believe
something like that happened and i find
that interesting because a lot of people
rag that i'm saying like all of a sudden
this guy who they say drifted to the
right is now you know all of a sudden
he's a conservative christian or
whatever and the funny thing is
the opposite kind of happens to me
because i've like long talked about how
i've believed in god since i was like 18
like i was grew up catholic then kind of
drifted away but then i was a teenager i
you know had this like realization and
now i believe in god but i don't
consider myself like religiously
theistic or anything like that not
following i don't follow scripture or
anything like that i just think there's
a god
and instead i get conservatives calling
me an atheist
i'm like why what is that all about i
don't know weird but i do think it's
interesting um so i just wanted to dig
on why you guys think religion is is
making a comeback
uh fundamentally everyone is
miss or um disoriented or misoriented
and is rudderless and unmoored and we're
all feeling it it's the you know the
chaos is
it's palpable you know and we feel it in
our own lives every day and so
everyone's looking for a rudder the rest
like we're just adrift in the ocean
right now and we're looking for
something to stick in the waves and try
to get back to shore uh religion has
worked for a long time you know
christianity is about 2 000 years old
judaism's what 5 000 years old or
something that's pretty firm solid
footing so i think it you know people
are looking that way because it's worked
i mean look at like p the peterson
phenomena but
like
he would
he would talk you know i've heard him
yeah jordan peterson thank you i've
heard him like be joke jokingly referred
to as like the guy who speaks to kids
who didn't have dads i mean maybe
there's some truth to that but i think
really like he was speaking to a
generation that was uh
sort of broken up by new atheism you
know like these these christian these
younger christian kids or jewish kids or
whatever that fell in love with dawkins
and hitchens and harris and these kind
of guys because they were charismatic
and really they're attacking
the argument level of like a
a teenager or whatever but they you know
if you don't know if you're not you know
well steeped or versed in your faith
then it's kind of easy to get you know
swayed by someone who is as charismatic
as hitchens so that went on for you know
a decade or whatever
and then
these these people that went through
that were looking at the society around
them and the chaos and disaster that it
had become and peterson steps up and in
many ways it's kind of like the anti-new
atheist he's like making similar
arguments but on the opposite end and
then those same kids like i remember
peterson talking about a bunch of
atheists showing up at his his things
and asking him about god and so i just
think that we're looking for
uh collectively we're looking for some
solid footing and religion has persisted
so scientific method kind of turns me
off i know there's real value to the
scientific method it's fantastic for
building machines and stuff but
placebo effect is real no one knows why
they just know it's somewhat effective
in studies and trials that's not
scientific method can't explain it so
that's not a perfect system and so i
look out i look elsewhere what else is
there quantum physics is fascinating
religions are fascinating god is
fascinating but to jump on one seems
like a a preemptive mistake so at least
that's where i'm at right now
i i somewhat agree i do think the
scientific method can eventually
understand why the placebo effect
happens i think we just haven't yet
because if you're going to keep doing
testing you figure out what you know
what's going on in the brain or in the
body but uh i somewhat agree you know
picking one religion that's why i
consider myself non-theistic in a sense
i don't follow any scripture or whatever
but i do believe you know god exists and
it's it's because
they're
i've met too many people who are like i
know for sure and here's why let me
explain it to you and i'm like man you
really are convinced you know a whole
lot you've asked a lot of deep
philosophical questions and here's
another guy who says you're wrong who's
also very learned you know so i'm like i
don't know i think the one thing i can
agree on is that there's something
bigger and greater than all of us but i
don't know if like maybe maybe the
reality is
everybody's looking through
the a small lens at the bigger picture
of the same thing
and you know they're looking through it
and they see imagine you're look this is
big mansion i always use example as a
ballroom inside with tons of people and
they're all dancing
and and you look through the keyhole
they're like what do you see what's
inside and like there's a big woman with
a big dress
then 10 feet down is a guy looking
through the same keyhole and he's like
he sees a guy wearing a tuxedo no it's
not it's a guy wearing a tuxedo and they
both started arguing like oh no no i i'm
seeing this he's like he's crazy look
and everyone's like i can see the lady
he's making it up depending on where
you're coming from you see something
different but what the reality is the
bigger picture on the inside is
everybody's getting little pieces of it
you know you think there's an objective
reality
yeah i do
how would you define it yeah
i mean seriously though i'm so glad he
asked you that question or nothing yeah
yeah
well i mean oh descartes makes me so
angry um
yeah i mean i see your point uh i i
think that it's
you have to live in the real world at
some point and for me it's like uh that
that's a table and let's say i went
outside and closed my eyes and i i
didn't even know i had no idea you were
there it was it was in the dark okay you
knew i was there but i had no idea that
you were there and you threw a snowball
and hit me in the side of the face
there was no chance that i could deny
the existence of that snowball that i
did not know existed before it struck my
face
so like obviously we react with the
material world you know and i do think
it's it's provable it's just that it's
you have to set up such bizarre
experiments to get there that it's
you get in circles that this is why
people often argue about what objective
and subjective is and it's like you know
you've got the brain in the vat thought
experiment maybe your brain's in a tube
and they're poking with electrodes maybe
we're all in the matrix maybe you at
home are the only real person and
everyone else is just some kind of video
game npc who knows how do you define
objective reality at it's the external
things that have a tendency towards
being true is the easiest way i can
think it like if i throw a rock at a
standard house window the window will
will break
or maybe you'll miss but we can
basically predict what's going to happen
physics physics is the most objective
reality i can figure at this point sort
of so the challenge is
some windows are bulletproof and so you
can be like i can prove to you objective
reality the window will break and you
throw it then it bounces off the window
and you're like okay i was wrong about
that well it doesn't disprove objective
reality just means there's such nuance
and subtleties to most things that
defining
reality
like defining objective reality is
is difficult because everyone has a
subjective perspective i suppose you
just look for the things that everyone
agrees upon as being true which is why
with the argument before about universal
objective morality to which i believe
there is one and it's because
when we were talking to jeremy uh boring
and michael knowles
and they were saying you know
essentially what's the point of a planet
without humans it's because we are human
we live within a human experience and
the human experience is our existence
without humans there's just you know
there's there's life but it's not
perceived the way we perceive it there's
no value to it the way we perceive value
it's literally just a rock and water or
something
so from the human experience i look to
what is true in every culture to every
person
throwing stepping on a rock hurts right
so we can see some things are objective
but it's a gradient you get to a certain
point where you're getting into physics
even and you might say i believe that
there are 13 dimensions here's the math
to prove it and someone else is going to
be like you're crazy there's 14 and
here's the math to prove it and then
you're getting into weird and wacky
world stuff because they're both right
you know if there's 14 that means
there's also 13 there's also 12.
well but you get my point like they'll
disagree on the math and and you know
ultimately the the fundamental nature of
the universe so how could it be
objective reality if the human
experience denies what is true i'll tell
you objective reality i gotta go to the
bathroom i will see you guys in two
minutes and i love it all right my point
is not that because too many a bunch of
people believe something is true
makes it true it's just that
if we can all prove something to a
certain degree and then we can replicate
it we've found our objective you know
reality to a certain degree it's it's
never it's never completely possible to
know everything why is the objective
reality discussion so fascinating like
i'm literally asking like why do you
think it is that we always come back to
that when when we have these discussions
why is it that uh this focus on uh like
i was talking someone earlier about uh
we always talk about common sense not
being that common anymore it seems like
people are taking this uh a very large
scale view when we've got plenty of
problems in the very very uh real world
that we're dealing with now so we have
these discussions and i always find that
it ends up distracting from actually
solving not to say that's not important
or that there's not value in the
discussion there is but i'm saying that
it usually comes up when we're
discussing real world issues and these
other things so i'm always fascinated
how we go back to these kind of more uh
larger scale discussions rather than
saying on the topics we were actually
discussing beforehand well i mean we're
talking about people becoming religious
and that was okay so like uh so for me
like when i was thinking about religion
like as somebody who's not uh not
denominational or anything like that but
i keep coming back to it recently
because of an absence of uh redemption
in the world we live in right now
there's absolutely like whether we're
talking about people who are like strong
proponents of cancer culture or if you
want to talk about ideological leftists
that are pushing these narratives right
now they don't really have much of a
belief in redemption at all and that's
something we went and saw father stu
which is like uh like we reviewed it for
the channel and i was like i was like
this might have been like a a six or
seven maybe but i gave it like a nine
just because seeing a story that was so
heavily focused on the idea of
redemption uh even if you exclude all of
the religious elements just that type of
of story is so missing and so lacking in
society today when you're not allowed to
redeem yourself once you're once you're
out once you're on the outs with the
group you're out forever and you're
never allowed back that's why that's why
they say you can never apologize because
if you apologize you're admitting fault
and then you're forever that person and
that sickens me in a lot of ways i don't
like the idea that you're knowing that
what you are at one time is who you are
forever and i take issue with that and
religion takes pains to make that a big
part of its uh of its value system and
that means a lot to me even if i can't
at this time say that i'm denominational
yeah but
i again it goes back to the communism
thing they it's not that they want you
out
as an outcast or whatever forever they
just want you broken submit to the group
yeah they just want you broken so that
they can mold you or use you or throw
you away or whatever and then that is to
your point uh the redemption arc that uh
uh religion allows for is
powerful and fundamental and in some
ways kind of what separates us from the
animal kingdom that we allow for things
like that
maybe that's
what's driving people back to religion
that they've seen cancel culture they've
seen the woke left and they've and
they've said i want to be a better
person i want to be redeemed i don't
want to be like that and so there's a
fundamental there's a moral structure
that says you can be redeemed you can be
forgiven which is the opposite of the
modern wokeness
but uh let's let's do this let's talk
about uh your book and uh your story you
want to explain what you know
tell us what your book is and what it's
about yeah um when i was i i joined the
military and then i got wounded over in
iraq and it's uh in 2006
got busted up pretty good broke on my
left tibia my left femur in three places
and my left hip in two places and my
right hip and one and my right femur in
two and my radius and ulna and my arm
and my right median nerve get transected
here and anyway just you know a host of
injuries my left humerus was broken all
by most all by ball bearings and i do
have a hole down here but um
so then i i came home and you know just
ties into this redemption arc
i came home and they had me on
uh you know obviously
they were having a hard time they didn't
know if i was gonna be able to walk
again and so i went through all of that
the physical recovery stuff and then
um i got to a civilian doctor out and
got out of the military hospital to a
civilian doctor and he went through the
pain medication that i was on and he was
like braxton i have women old women
dying of cancer that are on way less
than half of the amount of pain
medication you're on
so i was
hyper addicted to opioids didn't know it
at the time but hyper addicted to
opioids he started scaling me back and
then i went through about two years of
physical well first stage physical
therapy and then i started trying to get
off opiates you know and just
anyway so i went through struggles with
with all of that kind of stuff and um so
speaking to redemption arc i lived like
a complete dirt bag for a long time so
i'm very i'm very pro redemption myself
i am i'm also in recovery so that's uh a
large part of my story as well maybe
that i didn't even really connect that
when i was thinking about it here but
maybe that's why the idea of redemption
hits me so hard but uh i understand that
struggle for sure yeah man it's like
prodigal sons right you know went off
and lived in the underworld and now are
doing your best to climb your way out or
like as dostoyevsky writes about it as
like the underground but it's it's the
same it's you know the underground man
and everything's the same concept what's
the book called the glass factory
is there
so it's about your your redemption not
coming back from addiction and injury
honestly one of my favorite parts about
this book has been when i first wrote it
i was looking around and all the war
books that i was that i was saying were
just not reflective of the experience
and it's like i'm not trying to take a
shot at anybody but they were just not
reflective of the experience i was i was
seeing around me i was seeing my friends
you know several of them commit suicide
getting divorces going to jail losing
custody of their kids
you know
having problems and they the two choices
in literature that they sort of had were
uh either
uber hero stories you know that are um
anyway superhero type stories or this
this like very whiny
you know crybaby type thing and there
was no one trying to thread the needle
and say look yeah
a lot of us are screwing up and you need
to quit screwing up and
until you stop screwing up your life is
going to suck man like you got to get
out you know and do better so i tried to
kind of thread that needle and
what was the moment you realized and oh
man
i don't know it's funny i actually wrote
about this in the book too you might
like you would this this part of the the
book you would actually like i was
trying to
you know you're doing a lot of
self-reflection when you're writing
something like that and i was trying to
find this this moment and pinpoint it
when i when i decided to like be better
or whatever and what i realized is that
we all do this when we tell our own
stories like we look back in time for
this one thing that flipped the switch
or whatever but it's never true there
was always a series of small decisions
that led up to or away from making the
right one what was a couple of the
really big decisions you made that led
you
to the right to the path uh
i mean getting up at 5am helps for me
doesn't work for everybody but just
getting myself onto a schedule was a was
a big one um
what so i couldn't run for eight years
and then
one day i was able to kind of jog a
little bit again and i used to be you
know to be an athlete and so i really i
was very excited
at the possibility of running again so i
went and ran a mile with my buddy who's
runs endurance stuff and then i decided
to transfer that into going and hiking
the mauna kea in hawaii and so i had
like a goal to train for
and that was that was enormous for me to
like have something to orient myself at
physically so that i actually had to
like take care of my body you know and i
had gotten off of the opiates before but
then i was just you know still living
like an idiot and drinking too much
i want to ask for for both of you guys
actually you know being in recovery did
religion or god play a role in getting
off drugs
i mean for me for short was uh
i would say
the drug part well i was so lost still
at the time
um that i'm not sure
how much god really i mean god def so
this is where it gets hard it's like
maybe to my own neurotic selfish
uh you know in my own neurotic and
selfish mind god wasn't playing a role
but i think you know looking back i
think for sure god was playing a role
and now it helps a lot
i didn't have uh any uh such i don't
know if i would have been able to
process that type of a concept at the
time my brain was in such chaos
going through that but for me it was uh
and like we i was just discussing with
someone about this how there's no linear
like everyone looks for that moment
where they feel like they're getting
better or like this is the big decision
it's in the movies it's always somebody
gets in a car accident and they realize
they have to turn their life around but
for most people it's not something that
concrete you just have to make that
decision day by day and then suddenly
you find yourself on a path to do so and
for me it wasn't religion so much as it
was getting uh
finding firm footing on something i
wanted to do it was like skating for me
it was uh i had been sober for a while
and then my mom passed and then that
wasn't an event that led to it but it
changed things as far as my schedule and
my ability to open up my life because i
was at that time i was taking care of my
mom she was in poor health for many
years uh so the ability to get back out
in just physical activity played a huge
role in that and like you start uh you
know actively getting active again you
feel better about yourself and that
leads and it all becomes kind of like a
snowball rolling downhill uh and it's
just uh it wasn't god for me but it was
more the ability to take your life into
your own hands uh and push forward was
very um
monumental when you've been at the mercy
of something for so long the ability to
be in control of yourself again is uh
like i've told this story before like
when i when i realized that i could go
outside without uh or like i could get
up without being sick i cried i cried
for 20 minutes and that's because you've
now got control of yourself again you're
not beholden to something created by a
pharmaceutical company uh and that's a
revelatory experience that goes for like
i mean maybe that is uh uh god speaking
in a way but certainly it feels to be
akin to that
i'm thinking about the brain and all the
the the neurons and if that's connected
to the magnetosphere the extremely low
frequency band that's god and are you
part of it yeah you know that's what i
normally think about yeah self-control i
imagine if there is a god that it's
tightly interwoven
i just wonder because i hear a lot of
stories that you know a religious
experience or something was like force
pulling people i tell the story about
this guy i knew who's you know he's on
drugs and then he had a profound
experience where a voice told him to get
his life together and it made him very
religious i looked for something like
that you know like maybe it's just
because like i i talk about pop culture
all day i watch movies all day i'm
looking for that movie-like experience
that's going to bring me out of the the
situation i'm in and then one day you
just realize that is not the real for at
least not for everyone it won't be the
real world it won't be what everybody
experiences and you have to rely on
yourself again and uh maybe it would
have uh maybe selfishly i would have
loved to have had that but i still have
such a hard time asking those questions
about uh faith like
it's very hard for me to put my faith
all in something so perhaps he had a
different belief system that led him
more to find something like you know to
find his answers in that and i just
hadn't whatever wherever i was on my
journey just wasn't there yet so i had
to find my way a different way but it's
like that's that movie type way you
always imagine somebody pulling you back
um from the brink and that's just that
wasn't my experience but i almost would
have loved to have had that it feels
like that would have uh that would have
been benefit i think at the root of
every addict it fundamentally is
ingratitude for being you know it's like
just being angry at being so if you try
to cultivate gratitude in your life and
uh you know take yourself and and
however you want to think about this
bone sac that you occupy uh take start
to take that seriously then a lot of
your other problems will sort themselves
out uh we i used to talk about gratitude
as a superpower the ability to show
gratitude for uh at a certain point i'm
in a very cheap apartment i'm working
i'm barely making enough money to get by
but i'm skating every day and i'm doing
what i love and if i can go out every
day walk to get around do what i need to
do uh do something that i love while
having a job paying my bills and if i
can be extremely grateful for that that
is something that i feel like i feel bad
for people that can't find the gratitude
you know like i almost feel like they're
missing out on the ability to feel that
that emotion what's the best way to find
gratitude through pain
uh for me i i don't know if i find it
through pain i find it through getting
through the pain and finding yourself on
the other side of it and that's the
ability to handle it without help
or like without
the ability to find yourself through it
and still be okay not without help but
like the ability to you know to suffer
through it achieve uh you know get out
on the other side and find out that
you're still okay and you can still go
on there's gratitude in that for me
one of the best parts about that is that
we all embody that lesson and we don't
realize it like
when you go to the gym and lift weights
you have pain and you know it's sort of
a suffering experience and you do that
because you know that on the other end
you're going to be a stronger person and
we've known that since we were little
you know we learned this slowly over
time you know you're you're literally
embol embodying that uh
that story you know yeah thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
monday through friday at 8pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the tim cast irl podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
monday through friday at 8pm and we'll
see you all there